Oh mann eigentlich wollte die bundesregierung eine million elektroautos bis 2020 doch bisher passiert ist
Nichts beziehungsweise so gut wie nichts gestern war mein elektro-smart übrigens thema bei focus online weil das land berlin noch einen drauf
setzte reichweitenbeschränkung
durchlade zeitbeschränkung die neueste methode
Um interessenten für die elektromobilität abzuschrecken jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich verrückt da macht man sich beim kauf eines elektrofahrzeugs eine menge gedanken und zwar vor allem um ein thema wie
groß ist die reichweite eines elektroautos beim einem gebrauchten smart electric drive
Ist mit bis zu 150 kilometern?
Die schon ganz ordentlich vor allem für den stadtverkehr hier in berlin ist sie perfekt alle paar tage laden das passt ja
Wenn man das fahrzeug verladen könnte das geht nämlich in berlin nicht zumindest nicht mit meinem elektro-smart und vielen vielen anderen
elektrofahrzeugen auch nicht die betreiber des öffentlichen
ladennetzes stammen nämlich aus absurdistan und haben sich etwas ganz besonderes ausgedacht
Um die elektro autofahrer zu ärgern wenn die batterien heute schon einige hundert kilometer
Reichweite bieten dann beschränken wir doch die reichweite mit einer ladezeit begrenzung wort ja man glaubt es kaum tatsächlich
Sind die betreiber auf diese absurde idee gekommen und es ist überhaupt nicht erklärbar an der überbuchung der
ladesäulen kann es nicht liegen die sind nämlich fast alle immer frei was man hier auf der karte an den bunten blättern sieht höchstens
falschparken dem benziner machen sich hier breit und bei
bimobil
scheint so niemand richtig einen plan zu haben mir wurde geschrieben
Dass die meisten elektroautos heute schneller laden könnten und so die vier stunden ausreichen würden
Oh mann das ist wirklich ziemlich falsch
also erstens die meisten ladesäulen von b e mobil laden mit maximal elf kilowattstunden
sprich sie können gar nicht schnell laden ein tesla mit einer batteriekapazität von
85 kilowattstunden würde hier rund acht stunden brauchen selbst wenn er schnell laden könnte an den meisten sollen geht es eben nicht und zweitens
immer mehr elektrofahrzeuge haben
Solche immer größere batterien und können deshalb einfach nicht in vier stunden voll geladen werden wie immobilien wollte das
Missverständnis aufklären und rief mich an da hätten wir wohl etwas aneinander vorbei geredet meinte die nette dame. Am anderen ende der leitung und
Achtung. Jetzt kommt s isch hat sich denn da jemand gedanken drüber gemacht die antwort aus dem gedächtnis ja da würde ich sie schon von
ausgehen ich da zweifel ich aber dran tatsächlich scheint niemand darüber nachgedacht zu haben und das ist eine katastrophe in unserer bundeshauptstadt
Arbeitet man so gegen die elektromobilität und gegen eine stadt mit sauberer luft und auch an anderer stelle wird einfach nichts getan
Die durch bundesgesetz möglichen ausnahmen die benutzung der busspuren freies parken und so weiter für elektroautos in berlin gibt es
Nichts rein gar nichts es ist so peinlich und dabei und jetzt möchte ich mal kurz erklären warum ich hier
Kommentiere ist es für den klimawandel und um, ihn zu stoppen unabdingbar dass wir so schnell wie möglich auf saubere antriebe wechseln
wissenschaftlich tausendfach gefordert müssen wir runter von fossilen energien
Und es gibt keinen außer ein paar
Verteilten oder vielleicht donald trump noch die daran zweifeln nur hier in berlin tut man alles um diese entwicklung noch irgendwie
Zu bremsen das ist wirklich einfach nur unfassbar peinlich ich hoffe dass die berichterstattung vielleicht die ein oder andere schlafmütze in der berliner senatsverwaltung
auf weg frei nach dem motto guten abend meine damen und herren guten morgen liebe beamte
Falls sich hier etwas tut halte ich euch natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video
Dazu und auch, zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit bald nur noch elektroautos technik vor
Technologiesprung sei es richtig mit noch mehr infos zu ja. Zu allem was sich rund um elektromobilität
handelt also viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran